rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message invest in yourself
over to you Warren Buffett generally
speaking investing in yourself is the
best thing you can do anything that
improves your own talents ly nobody can
take it away from me they can run up
huge deficits and the dollar can become
worth far less you can have all kinds of
things happen but if you've got talents
yourself and you've maximized your
talent you've got a terrific asset and
that doesn't mean everybody should go to
college but it it doesn't mean that any
way you find to improve communication
skills are enormously important I mean I
took a Dale Carnegie course that I paid
$100 for and it was worth a college
degree at least I thought it was what I
loved about this clip is you've got
Warren Buffett the single greatest
investor of all time telling you that
the best investment you can ever make is
in yourself he's not saying go buy a
stock he's not saying go buy a company
not even saying go be an entrepreneur or
get a job or go to university it's in
yourself the best investment from the
best investor is always gonna be in
yourself and I 100% agree if I look back
on my career you look at YouTube since
you guys are familiar with the channel
the best investment I made at the
beginning was in one learning how to do
everything so I could become a youtuber
but then the higher that I made invested
in my business to bring on my first
editor allowed me to go from making a
video a week max to video a day hiring
that editor part-time
allowed me to seven times my output
because I hated editing and I was really
slow at it and it wasn't really good at
it either and it allowed me to do more
of what I love and so investing into my
business had a huge impact if I just
took that money and put it in the stock
market or poured it into real estate and
I'm earning seven to ten percent a year
or fifteen percent a year are the
highest or whatever it's gonna be it's
way less compared to what I ended up
creating this entire business I don't
know how much percentage return it is
way more than seven to 15% a year and so
that invested myself made a huge
difference I also believe in in what I'm
doing here with the
Tube channel I believe the world's
single biggest problem is untapped human
potential is that people are not doing
what they're supposed to be doing
they're locked into doing jobs that they
hate doing work that they don't love and
if they just unlock that piece and did
the thing that they had Michael Jordan
level talent at the world would be an
amazing place to live in and that's my
mission that's what I'm on every day to
try to fight and make better and I
believe a huge part of that solution is
education is this it's here you have
free content to consume and get better
and learn and get educated every single
day you know if you go to university you
may not have Warren Buffett come in and
speak to you maybe if you're lucky he
comes in for one day at a commencement
speech but here on this channel you get
Warren Buffett and and his peers every
single day three times a day giving you
knowledge giving you resources giving
you motivation giving you inspiration
giving you ideas on how to unlock your
potential and how to be successful on
how to find fulfillment for yourself and
so I think if you want to live a great
life if you want to have a big impact a
huge chunk of that comes from
continually investing in yourself to
improve to not be locked in to the
environment that you are born in and
raised in and grew up in and just do the
life that your parents want you to live
to be the break free and find the thing
that you love doing and have the courage
confidence boldness the chase after that
with all your heart to go off I make
that huge impact in the world so the
question of date today is I'm curious
what is a single greatest investment in
yourself that you have ever made I would
love to hear from you please leave it
down in the comments below thank you
guys as well for watching I believe in
you a hope we'll continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
I spray so give me go
when I started I just I just devoured
comedy I went to clubs every night even
if I wasn't I'd be on stage maybe twice
a week but I was at Club seven nights a
week I'd watch every comedian I could
good or bad friend or foe didn't matter
I just watched and and just loaded it
into my system as well I'm the same way
if I didn't know I mean here's why see
how they do it are they doing if you're
in London watch everybody you can see
right are they doing it differently
is there a style that's interesting yeah
in the end you have to be yourself you
have to find your own sense but there's
always something to learn about the
approach that somebody maze whether it's
a baseball player watching another
baseball player right because the
baseball player is watching another
player but he's watching baseball he's
watching this they're all doing the same
game you know so the game is so the same
in stand-up whatever the comic is doing
is not in a vacuum you're watching
stand-up happen you're watching and how
audiences are reacting and the audience
is such a mysterious animal to us you
know so you're always kept guessing
there's some nights you go to a club and
you're like you know I feel good I'm
ready to do have a good show but the
audience has a strange unanimous grumpy
feeling to them or something and how did
the all these people they're all
strangers to each other
but they've they're all saying that we
hate this show like how is this
happening
oh yes I'm Colin spuds yes oh I'll never
see enough shows to go okay I get this
yeah you know so it's an in unquenchable
thirst your level of ability in your
field will determine the quality and
quantity of your results the better you
get at what you do the easier is that
for you to start moving forward and to
get a particular
as you increase your skill level in your
field through study and experience you
get better and better at doing the small
things that increase the speed and
predictability of your results remember
skills are things that can be developed
over and over and all business skills
are learn about you can learn any skill
you need to learn to achieve any
business goal that you can set for
yourself set yourself up to win now this
may sound easy but let me give you some
insight into brain chemistry
now one of my my good friends Dave
Asprey from the bulletproof team yeah
amazing man
shared this with me and that is that the
brain although its 150th of the body
weight takes up 20% of the calories 20%
of the energy in your body goes to run
your brain now if that energy is low
guess what you feel demotivated and a
lot of the time people try and rely on
willpower but willpower isn't on demand
willpower has cycles based upon whether
your brain is being fed the energy it
needs so if you are feeling down and
thinking hard to say I was gonna commit
to that but I can't I just not in the
mood and you don't want to work harder
then first things first
go check your brain chemistry and get
yourself some fast yeah sugars into the
diet yeah some high quality brain fuel
to be able to perk yourself back up at
that level then go do it another great
way of setting yourself up to win is
that when you're in the mood to do
something prepare something for when
you're going to be doing the project in
other words I'll give you an example if
you go to bed at night put your gym kit
at the bottom of the bed if you're going
to the gym in the morning research has
shown if you get out of bed and that gym
kit is more than 20 seconds away you're
not likely to make it if you're not in
the mood but if your gym kit is at the
foot of the bed and you get out and the
first thing you do is put it on you're
ahead of the game set yourself up to win
yeah so when I'm in the mood and I am
energized my brain chemistry's high and
I'm associated to it to what I'm doing
do something in that moment to take
action towards setting yourself up when
you know predictably that cycle is going
to dip because you can't be an uptime
all the while that's a superhuman myth
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or that would be like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details